- last day so we got you gift where are
you going after this it's a really sad
week this week as many of you know and
Carmichael is taking off he's moving on
to greener pastures this week is his
last week and it's kind of weird I'm
gonna be honest I've been working with
Carmichael closely back-to-back for
almost four years you don't really see
much of him on camera but there's been a
lot of really funny moments little bits
throughout the years that have been
simple memorable and I think each of us
want to go through with him and just
embarrass the heck out of them and go
through all these moments we here at
Ramirez the local bounty of craft beer
and liquor it's the end of my five years
I want to give a gift for giving me this
job then this big chunk of what feels
like my career here's something that you
personally can enjoy and every time you
take a sip of it he's another thing of
me feels good walking out of a liquor
store at 11 a.m. for Sam Nico and Jake I
got a little whiskey shot a bullet
bourbon you got a basil Hayden just wait
for the opportune moment waiting till
the opportune moment to give the goodbye
gift is crucial to any goodbye man stuff
in the back for a little bit with me and
we go through the last day and we we got
you something so I'm just trying to just
want to destroy you - all right
remember the opportune moment oh all
right are you ready for this that's a
pretty good gift ring on all right got
me a laptop no I didn't get I brought
over my laptop so we can get you a
year's subscription to expressvpn this
is a sponsored segment of course today's
sponsor is expressvpn Carmichael I don't
think you really realize what we're
getting you here you see this is the
best easiest most trusted way to explore
the Internet and protect your internet
privacy I'll get you started seven bucks
less than seven bucks among its okay
with a 30-day money-back guarantee it
works anywhere in the world on any
device laptops phones tablets so it's
okay you don't you don't you don't have
to do it no trust me you know but you
really are gonna need this you're gonna
be traveling the world making all these
things and we're gonna sign you up for a
year because if you sign up for a year
using expressvpn comm / corridor crew
yeah you get three months free you got
three months free I film you just go to
e XP ress VPN dot-com slash corridor
crew you know that's it that's all you
have to do to sign up you ready I'm all
good I'm all good dude seriously this is
from us to you man just go to expressvpn
comm slash core crew and be like
Carmichael protect yourself anywhere in
the world
it's fine I know we've we filmed this
before it's all good let's just close
this out we're all good Oh cute we're
all good what we're all good we're all
good thanks wait thanks man
go to expressvpn dot-com slash corridor
crew he just stole my laptop
[Music]
they invited seemed like I'm the crazy
guys don't be weird then that's been
being weird I've only been here for
about a year I barely know the guy you
were kind of hearing comical is here
you're working on the division and
snapper here yeah weird that he was
doing their t-shirts in source although
zeros t-shirts the first thing we ever
did with Carmichael was he was a PA for
a week on shadow of mordor that we shot
during this summer
specifically July of 2014 we've done a
video board you were like the
camaraderie that week I took off at my
other job for no pay to work with you
guys and then I went back to the job got
fired
nice called Jake and I got a job you
want to say what they learned that was
star citizen yeah kinda Michael was the
guy editing that like developer videos
for you from sources and this is a full
year and a half before we ever started
the blogs this is my second job after
film school is there the beginning of
the first shot this is the beginning of
an era right there that video is the
very first time we started doing the
blog here and for like the first few
months it always felt like it was
basically just Carmichael and I sitting
next to each other I even had the camera
on just like what Jake's desk was right
here this is Ellis Ellis a stylist fine
oh yeah
I told Carmichael that I think Nick can
get two fives to get a hundred thousand
views within two weeks of each other we
can get the new cameras for the blocks
they're shooting on the Sony tx1 and ID
at the very end of the Star Wars drones
BTS the cameras yeah and it just won't
focus again this is a blast and Dubai
right yeah this is Carmichael's first
time crying on camera we were only there
for a weekend and then we flew back oh
my it was like so okay what do we do on
this trip Carmichael we went up to the
top of the Burj Khalifa and what
happened so Carmichael has a deathly
fear of heights the Burj Khalifa is the
tallest skyscraper in the world walk
back when I saw it so it was Craig and
Bryan I we were like this is kind of
funny Carmichael you should really lean
up against the glass and look down
[Music]
[Laughter]
heart wasn't racing but all my pores
across the whole body will focus
interesting wedding well they say that
your Heights isn't if your they'll fall
with the fear that you'll jump so wrens
on his electric bike he just built and
Carmichael is filming trend from the one
wheel and they come around a corner and
rinses C microwave the one we like a pro
and immediately after he just sees
people ask me sage this we definitely
did not
this is blew my mind because I'm ever
you see sliding I remember when we first
got this huge inflatable bubble balls
dude your cars been in a lot of videos
it's actually doing EVD yeah Kon
Speedway
first thing you do
[Music]
we're saying because Jake in my head up
and Sam's head dude 4head he looks like
Hurricane Hugo Weaving dude Sam is not a
Neanderthal so I had had two ideas
behind it
one was bored - it comes back to
psychology the first thing that you see
in the room is a human face and the the
thing that you could see before a human
face is the wrong human face so in a
crowd of white people the black guy is
gonna stand out crowd of black people
the white guy's gonna stand out so my
thought was what if I the human face
enough that it still looks like a human
face but doesn't would it catch your eye
as a thumbnail - Tim I wouldn't eat that
one yeah it does catch your eye definite
it repels you
all right increase the size of his mouth
under the mask your mouth your mouth and
your nose it's like a lizard
all right 1.5 now yeah at 1.5 million
yesterday I started working here at two
hundred and two hundred twenty four
thousand seven hundred and ten
Wow yeah it's been a run or Michael
we're gonna miss you I'm glad we had to
hear to help make all this possible
you guided the way very effectively
where are you going after this I'm sorry
Andy Andy channel called fables of
Refuge something magical happened
playing D&D I had a feeling come over me
and it was the same feeling I had when
my dad first brought me to the
Renaissance Fair I was six years old and
I realized whatever this feeling is I
need to take it nurture it and grow it
and then my brain just started going how
can you turn D&D into a book how can you
do short films around D&D then I was
like okay I'm being overwhelmed by this
I should probably tell these guys now
I'm leaving sooner than later so this
was basically your passion project for
the last year and now you're going to
pursue that full-time
yeah trying to say let's go subscribe if
you would like to keep up with me if you
love D&D if you like fantasy if you like
storytelling head over to tables of
refuge oh you got a patreon I got a
patreon you know your first video up I
have my first video of that thumb down
dude thousand subscribers already
yeah it's man yeah I'm sure you guys
I'm gonna call you for freelance
projects and available when I met you
you were just a young man and now you're
a man
[Music]
I'd be sad but I have all the videos and
we made together
oh oh wait wait the camera guy juice the
Carmichael and all the growth and
stories and emotions and things we've
learned from each other on this channel
and with you and tables of refuge
torturing past me I'm not a whisky
drinker but and that was really good
you know it's your last day so we got
you a gift
starting by the back room with me real
quick for real for real inside of this
backpack is a subscription to roan your
internet freedom it was in there a
beautiful award-winning it's been good
yeah the Jarrett's our Dungeon Master
four players Ally Jess Carter and Laura
I would love and appreciate the
opportunity to show you what I could do
with something I love outside of
corridor digital please subscribe and
click the belt and the rest of 2019
planned out and scheduled everything
I've learned and done over the last five
years at corridor has led to this I
would love for you to be there with me
thank you and I'll see you out there
[Music]
you